heute meine damen und herren kommen wir
zum höhepunkt und zwar dem unseres
gesamten basel 1 es geht um eine
erfahrung die fast jeder erwachsene
kennt und der doch etwas rätselhaftes
jahr unheimliches anhaftet die rede ist
vom orgasmus was ist damit
bedenkenswertes auf sich hat erkunden
wir heute mit dem philosophen und
komponisten klaus steffen mahnkopf der
unlängst eine philosophie des orgasmus
vorgelegt hat sowie der sexologin und
paartherapeutin an marlene haring in
balken ein herzliches gekommen frau
henning wir haben jetzt diese sendung
rätsel orgasmus genannt das ist ja schon
mal mit tese in der setzung stimmt das
denn überhaupt ist daran etwas
rätselhaft und was genau passieren na ja
also ich denke schon mittlerweile weiß
man viel drüber
also man könnte sagen das ist erstmal
kein rätsel weil man kann immer durch
die bildgebenden verfahren und so kann
man genau sehen wenn man da bei der frau
da und da in der vagina dann da und da
im gehirn und als man kann es sehr gut
zeigen in bildern aber beschreiben kann
ihn noch keiner was ist es was wir da
wirklich erleben also da gibt es so
viele beschreibungen wie es menschen
gibt und deswegen bleibt zum glück ein
rätsel
es ist irgend ein schönes wahnsinniges
gefühl wo wir endlich also ohne zu
wollen gleich los lassen also das soll
so bleiben finde ich schade diese
faszination für sie habe mal im kopf
auch den grund oder die motivation eine
philosophie des orgasmus das kann oder
was ist für sie das philosophisch
rätselhafte daran also zunächst einmal
staune ich immer wieder bis in meine
hohes alter jetzt über den orgasmus dass
es eben dieser intensität überhaupt gibt
das ist erstmal eine erfahrung die ich
als mensch gemacht habe und dann habe
ich vor etwa 15 jahren festgestellt dass
in der fach philosophie dieses wort das
heißt also die sache und der begriff
überhaupt nicht vorkommt selbst wo es
sich anbietet
das heißt ich staunte darüber dass die
philosophie nicht staunt obwohl das
staunen eigentlich so viele so viel eher
über diese leerstelle in der philosophie
auch und dann reifte mit der zeit
na ja man könnte man sollte und dann
irgendwann der punkt schreibe ich das
wirklich weil das ist naja und dann die
öffentlichkeit damit aber es war klar
ich mache das nur mit unseriösen verlag
und das hat geklappt und sonst hätt' ich
das buch nicht geschrieben eine
vermutung besteht ja darin die
philosophie der letzten 2500 jahre wurde
maßgeblich fast hauptsächlich von
männern betrieben wäre das dann anders
wenn mehr philosophen da gewesen wären
oder anders gefragt ist der orgasmus aus
weiblicher perspektive eine ganz anderes
thema hat andere wichtigkeit
naja das an sich die frage an sich man
könnte vermuten das ist nämlich schon
ein klischee dies ist das weib hat die
besseren die größeren die multiplen
orgasmen oder so aber da glaube ich ist
das eine technische handhabe aus meiner
erfahrung jetzt als paartherapeutin ich
sitze mit vielen dienten männer können
genau die gleichen dinge erleben also
heftigere noch heftigere orgasmen augen
mehrere aber sie tendieren dazu bei der
erregung selbst ich bin jetzt ganz
konkret schnelle treiben einzusetzen an
einem ort und dann ist das was sich
entlädt automatisch ein bisschen weniger
als wenn man länger braucht und den
ganzen körper mit einbezieht also ich
glaube es gibt kaum ein unterschied wir
aber die tendenz ist daher dass man
immer noch behauptet beim weit sei es so
anders wir sehen ganz eine schöne
balance zwischen praxis und theorie aber
dennoch 2500 jahre schreiben männer über
alles mögliche über glückseligkeit über
glück nicht über den orgasmus also und
die sexualität und über den leib hat man
bis zum anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts weder in der philosophie
noch in den geisteswissenschaften groß
gesprochen
das wird dann erst zum thema und vor
allem sagen wir mal den letzten 50
jahren mit so einem gewissen existenz
ihren törn
aber dann hätte man das ja erst recht
erwarten können dass die große
philosophen endlich mal was dazu sagen
der derrida sagte so schön
er bedauere es dass die großen
philosophen also kann über ihre
sexualität gesprochen hätte was wussten
wir hätten sie das getan
aber er hat das auch nicht gemacht ich
wäre da hat dazu auch nichts gesagt und
stellen sie sich mal vor herber mars
oder herr sloterdijk würde würden würden
konkret werden das machen dem nicht aus
scham aus professional also einer
deformation professionell oder weil man
und das ist eben mein ansatz man kann
sich dem orgasmus philosophisch dann
doch nicht abstrakt theorie nur
theoretisch nähern sondern man muss das
umfänglich phänomenologische machen und
dann muss man sich auch noch auf sehr
viele sachen einlassen und sich auch ein
bisschen den bloßen man kann daraus
nicht in der dritten person erbringe
sondern muss dass ich einbringen ein
grund warum der orgasmus etwas
verunsichern dass gerade verändert sein
könnte den schauen wir uns jetzt in
einer ikonisch gewordenen film szenen
aus dem film harry und sally da tut
nämlich ganz öffentlich etwas was
offenbar viele frauen tun sind nur
simuliert einen orgasmus schauen jetzt
das mal an
bei henning und die szene geht weiter
dann sagen eine frau genau das was sie
hat möchte ich auch haben das ein
komisches potenzial wer aber ist ja auch
erst mal die frage vielleicht an die
expertin ist das denn gut dargestellt
würden sie sagen plausibel
naja ich finde es sehr plausibel aber
jeder das anders ich glaube eine
drohende der der deutsche komiker jürgen
von der lippe er macht hat eine chance
wo er das beschreibt und und und
beschreibt das sieht aus wie eine der
bekannten disney figuren diese nahm ich
jetzt nicht weiß mit einer großen
erkältung also das ist also man sieht es
gibt andere videos im internet dazu das
ist leidend aussieht also wenn man
wirklich die gesichter eines menschen so
nah ran sodass kommen in beim kommen ist
es was sehr erschreckendes wenn man sich
vorstellt dass zum beispiel ein kleines
kind ins zimmer kommt oder man hat so
eine angst dass man gesehen wird den
kinder was sehen kriegen die oft ängste
wenn sie es hören und sehen es ist sehr
laut brutal weil wir uns gehen lassen
ich finde es ja das toll gemacht also
auch diese ambivalenz zwischen höchster
lust und schmerz ihrer erkrankung die
sehen wir hier schon aber es zeigt sich
ja vor allem wenn wir von andersheit
sprechen eine erste große andersheit
hermann kopf die frau mutmaßlich kann
den orgasmus simulieren und der man kann
das in dieser weise stimmt weiß ich
nicht aber das ist kein thema und warum
glauben sie ist das kein thema ok also
die sich schon gesagt haben freihändigen
der männliche und der weibliche orgasmus
ist physiologisch auch von der von der
wirkungsweise und von der genetischen
herkunft identisch lasst den kleinen
unterschied im vier stufen modell von
master & johnson ist die rückbildung
phase beim mann so geht ganz schnell und
anschluss oder frau nicht dass deswegen
ist sie wieder empfänglich für weiteres
und auch für weitere orgasmen und dieser
kleine unterschied der sich ergibt aus
der fortpflanzungs notwendigkeit hat
dann wenn man das hochrechnet
unglaubliche kulturelle auswirken ja das
ist genau der punkt das heißt also es
ist auch bislang nicht geklärt worden
warum es den weiblichen orgasmus
überhaupt gibt
und einer erklärung ist dass die frau
dem mann signalisiert ja du bist der
richtige partner
sie spürt sozusagen in ihrer
ekstatischen los dass das in der
zweisamkeit funktioniert und der ist
eben nicht funktioniert und aber sie
vielleicht ein kind will oder überhaupt
sie will und sie will es möglich schnell
vorbei ist kann ja auch sein ganz
ignoriert sie das um den mann zu
verstehen zu geben
du machst das auch an aber es gibt ja
ein großes thema dahinter ein
philosophisches thema das es skepsis
ich bin skeptisch ob ich überhaupt das
ziel erreicht habe dass ich erreichen
wollte beim man kann man sagen gibt es
ein offenbar als zeichen die ejakulation
die gleichsam ein beweis charakter
hatten bei der frau so nicht das ist
doch schon ein unterschied in bezug auf
die fähigkeit die simulierte des
orgasmus ja ja genau ich erinnere mich
aber noch daran als ich das erste mal
von einem männlichen vom klienten hörte
dass er vor spielt da war meine erste
reaktion wie geht das denn und bds
machen weil das ist nämlich hier der
fall das machen auch männer oft aus weil
sie keine lust mehr haben das muss jetzt
zu ende sein
dann dann aber geht es sehr gut mit
kondomen und so dann macht man schnell
so ich geh mal kurz also man kann auch
dieses diesen beweis unterschlagen
verschwinden lassen
ich wollte würde gerne kurzen
zurückspringen weil haben so viele dinge
in dem was sie gesagt habe gerade zu
diesen unterschied zwischen frauen und
männern und ich kriegte gerade den
gedanken genetisch gesehen ja der mann
und frau sind zugleich und deswegen
überlege ich werden sie nicht auch
gleich eventuell wenn in dem orgasmus
und in dem ganzen körperlichen ich komme
jetzt wenn wenn frauen nicht über so
viele jahre hunderte von jahren lernen
würden ihr geschlecht sei dreckmann soll
nicht anfassen also frauen kennen
einfach ihren körper nicht ich kenne
viele frauen die schnell kommen können
sie ihren körper kennen und männer die
nicht kommen können also da es sind sehr
viel mehr ähnlichkeit als man
unmittelbar vermutet ich glaube das
liegt er diese nicht ähnlichkeit an der
hand habe dass frauen einfach immer
waidmarkt wird nicht anfassen und du
kannst es nicht aber es erstmal in das
neunte these das was wir zu sagen
natürlich evolutionär beschreiben ist
generell so überformt das erste
eigentliche grund sein könnte
ja wie oft geschieht in das aus ihrer
praxis als paartherapeutin wie oft
simulieren und die regelmäßig frauen in
orgasmus und wie sehr belastet das sehr
oft tun sie das anscheinend bei den
umfragen heißt es ja immer 90 95 prozent
und ich kenne das bin nicht ich habe das
noch nie gemacht ist wichtig dass die
ddr oder der gedanke ist wäre warum
sollte ich aber scheint ja irgendetwas
sofort zu herrschen also dass das weiß
jeder muss kommen und dieser druck wird
immer stärker
dann hab ich nen guten grund und die
frauen dies tun sagen ich wollte mein
partner nicht enttäuschen
also dieser beweis ist nicht da dann
gebe ich ihm so ich sage und zeige ich
bin gekommen
also das sind riesen themen ich merke
gerade ich würde jetzt eine stunde sagt
wir haben eine ganze stunde an einer
spectra auch schon hervor
orgasmus als ziel beschreibung eines
aktes ist und damit auch einen gewissen
druck erzeugt lässt sich auf etwas ein
und beide haben ein ziel der eine weiß
er hat es erreicht der andere weiß es
nicht das ist ja schon mal eine starke
und bucht im in diesem dialogischen
verhältnis also es gibt eine wunderbare
stelle von simone depot war in ihrem
klassiker das andere geschlecht her die
das beschreiben sagt mein mann ist
relativ klar das ist eine funktion das
hat eine absicht und das eint finales
geschehen
und dann ist ruhe und hat beschreibt sie
die frau eigentlich müssten heute die
feministischen an die decke gehen ja wie
sie das macht weil sie dann nicht ganz
realistisch sagt naja oder frau ist viel
komplizierter
sie hat auch ihre wohnen und die hat
auch ihre lust und ihre freude aber
letztlich nie so befriedigt wie der mann
es sein wird
so jetzt ist die frage stimmt dass jetzt
die frage ist jetzt jetzt haben wir
keine studien über das die erlebnis
fähigkeiten oder wir die erlebnisse des
orgasmus weltweit
ich frage mich immer was ist im iran zu
quatschen ja also wir reden hier über
einen relativ liberale westliche
gesellschaft und jetzt kommt ihr gedanke
mit dieser gewalt geschichte männern
gegenüber frauen und die es ja uralt
dass wir irgendwann das angefangen hat
und das
so genetisch also genetisch fast
wahrscheinlich auch tatsächlich
genetisch aber kulturell so verankert
dass wir nicht wissen können wie es wäre
wenn mann und frau vor allem frau
tatsächlich vollständig befreit wäre
also was lang wäre das können wir nicht
antizipiert vielleicht letzten 200
jahren vielleicht in 500 jahren
wir wissen das nicht und da muss man
immer aufpassen es ist meines erachtens
zu einfach zu sagen das ist alles
kulturell ja und ja aber dann ist es
auch die sache mit der wir umgehen
müssen und dann gibt es natürlich diese
biologischen unterschiede und dann
dazwischen gibt es die so wahnsinnig
vielen anhänger und die machen die diese
frage auch so schwierig und das ist ja
das zwischen verhältnis das uns zu
menschen macht zwischen natur und kultur
und gerade an diesem ereignis sieht man
wie schwer das im einzelnen überhaupt
voneinander sagen ja zu trennen also ich
muss ich muss unbedingt auch einspringen
was heißt also ich bin dann nicht einig
mit simon tobor dies dass die frau ist
nie ganz befreit also das muss kulturell
sein weil ich kenne nur leute frauen aus
meinem masterstudium aus meinem privaten
kreis oder klienten dass das frau
genauso ausgiebig ergiebig kommen kann
und nicht also entweder le petit mort
dass man hat keine kontrolle genau der
kleine tod also völlig befreit
das ist dann wird es schnell politisch
nehme ich mir das recht egal ob ich
lerne mein geschlechtes dreckig passiv
und geschlecht ich fasse einfach gar
nicht will meinen körper kennen es gibt
studien die dazu die zeigen dass das ist
das körperteil das weibliche genital von
dem frau am wenigsten weiß laden sie
mich da wenn das das ist ja furchtbar
das oft gar nicht erschlossen und
gewusst wird das ist eine tatsache und
ein klein erhielt claire film zu dieser
tatsache haben wir auch vorbereitet auch
zeigt wie stark das immer auch kulturell
mit überformt ist über den vaginalen und
in klitten orgasmus daniel hart
wackernagel professor für biologie an
der universität basel beschäftigt sich
intensiv mit dem
welchen erregungs system was ist dran am
mythos des vaginalen höhepunkt das ist
ein riesiges glaubenskrieg
in copiapo wissenschaftler und es gibt
kein marginalen orgasmus es gibt kein tv
es gibt nur ein glied oralen orgasmus
alles was der frau los macht ist das
organ beschränkt
sigmund freud der trieb papst aber war
es der seinerseits genau das gegenteil
behauptete anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts spaltete er den weiblichen
höhepunkt unterschied zwischen dem
reifen und dem unreifen orgasmus können
sie mal raten welcher von beiden der
bessere war natürlich der vaginal also
der unreife war der krieg orale das
heißt den die frau über masturbation
sich selber verschaffen konnte und der
reife war der vaginale der nur in dem
rahmen der penetration mit einem mann
stattfinden konnte dort die sprache
parallelisierung sie ist natürlich die
lose brown forbes und christa marx und
dass selbst die machtposition hat der
kreative frauen immer stärker worte sind
ja und viele frauen waren total
verzweifelt die frauen haben jahrzehnte
lang versucht einen vaginalen orgasmus
zu bekommen und haben das dann
geschrieben und dann waren andere wieder
ganz verzweifelt um mein gott ich kann
ihn nicht erreichen ich bin keine
richtige frau oder so und es ist einfach
quatsch der frau die kompetenz zur
sexuellen selbst erfüllen absprechen
ein machtmittel park wackernagel will
mit seinen recherchen einem immer noch
verbreiteten und halbwissen über das
weibliche erregungs system
entgegenwirken
und weist auf die potenz der klitoris
hin bei der die eichel nur die spitze
des eisbergs ausmacht das wegerecht
systemische keine verwies vielflieger
stars vom war und was zuerst nur neue
studie zeigt sind dass jede beere
katharina ihnen oder russe führt dazu
eine bewegung thema richtig system und
durch das ist völlig nun sehen marginal
zu unterscheiden von guido rahn
das ist ein großes system extrem
miteinander verknüpft und vorbau tisch
ein haus gehört kampfgebiet in das
gebiet große streit herein erst mal
vielleicht für bekenntnisse gibt es
diesen unterschied für sie und welche
bedeutung hatte
den gibt es nur im kopf und zwar als
problem weil die leute das immer noch
glauben das ist so ein unterschied gibt
und dieser vaginale so habe ich mag ist
die meg ryan und der andere ist so und
es ist einfach quatsch also ich bin
komplett einig mit diesem herrn und
sogar darin dass es gar nicht mehr so
viel unsicherheiten gibt wieder kurz
gesagt wird also das ist sehr gut
erforscht
aber die frage ist wie viel davon wird
publiziert so dass auch jeder lesen kann
also das ist das wissen gab es ja auch
schon vor 200 jahren zu diesem organ die
schönsten zeichnungen sind diese alten
bleistift also von den anatom im
frühjahr rinaldo und es gibt ein paar
bekannte die schon beschrieben die
klitoris als das schöne organ genauso
groß wie da also das hat wieder ich
würde vermuten was mit machtverhältnisse
oder jemandem was absprechen also was
ganz klar ist die klitoris der frau ist
das aerogel also das am meisten gene
also überhaupt das empfindliches organ
am ganzen menschlichen körper also
vielleicht wenn man gewagt sagen darf
doppelt so empfindlich wie die leiche
des mannes also und ist so groß und
meine meinung ist und das kann ich
bestätigen durch frauen die sich damit
beschäftigen ich selber auch das ist
einer der immer ein choral orgasmus ist
auch der innere das sind dann eben
innere anteile und g punkt ist gut dass
der verschwundene ist wieder her sagte
aber es gibt so was wie eine geht's ohne
kann ich als frau selber bestätigen
alles
ist eng verbunden mit nerven quasi genau
hinter der perle auf der innenseite
laufen ganz viele nervenendigungen
zusammen dort untersucht auch in
bildgebenden verfahren und so weiter und
hermann kopf was wir sehen hier es gibt
eine sehr mächtige kulturelle
beschreibung die von sigmund freud
die eine ideologische und qualitative
differenzierung vornimmt die jetzt unter
dem verdacht steht ein anatomisches
korrelat zu haben sondern einfach ein
machtinstrument der männlichen
beschreibung des weiblichen orgasmus ja
nun da führen wir die wissenschaft also
wir haben ja noch ein anderes problem
die verteufelung der masturbation das
fing um 1700 an die 200 jahre lang mit
der behauptung man würde krank würde
sterben das wäre einfach alles ganz
schrecklich und viele haben das
übernommen sowie manuel kann charles
dickens je hygieniker die die theologen
alle und dann fängt die wissenschaft an
am ende des 19 jahrhunderts bis
unternehmen sonst jahrhunderten
festgestellt alles stimmt nicht damit
war das widerlegt das heißt also die
wissenschaft hat die funktion
aufzuklären
also die dinge so zu mal beim namen zu
nennen und wie es wirklich ist und es
tatsächlich so wie sie sagen also das
ist schon fast dass wir männer dann ist
fast eigentlich schon
minderwertigkeitskomplex sind das also
dass last der lust der luftraum oder
dieses organ viel größer als was wir so
haben was ich ja dann auch zu der these
ummünzen
naja dann können wir männer von den
frauen eigentlich mehr lernen als
umgekehrt vorüber da die männer wieder
sauer sind
es gibt ja diese gestalt in der
griechischen mythologie von der man sagt
sie hat einmal eine frau gewesen und
dann zum angewöhnen theresias der dann
berichtet das sei etwa neunmal so stark
der weibliche organist jan hohe
evolutionäre ungerechtigkeit kann man
sagen sagt nicht einmal einen
intensiveren orgasmus und die allgemeine
lust fähigkeit der insgesamt sei bei
frauen höher das findet man auch in der
in der indischen mythologie schon
derzeit und dann habe ich mich gefragt
ja ist das so und ich habe es mal
angenommen dass das tatsächlich so ist
naja vielleicht stellt sich dann heraus
wenn diese entzündung ist
geschlechterverhältnisse in etwa 1000
jahre abgeschlossen ist dass wir dann
wirklich alle gleich sind aber das wäre
ja auch viel
ich gar nicht mal so gut also wenn die
frau tatsächlich andere qualitäten hat
als männer
dann würde ich das ehrt grüßen das was
er begrüßt cousteau ja also wegen des
erdfalls einfach auch also wenn wir
jetzt über den gender diskurs mann und
völlig gleich machen also ich meine es
nicht gleichberechtigt sondern wirklich
an allen ebenen ein ebenen er alle
eigenschaften sind so zu letztendlich
dann doch die gleichen eine kleine zu
sagen und sucht indem sie haben am
anfang gesagt es gibt diese differenzen
gar nicht so stark auch der man kann
diese lust empfinden und ein hat
andererseits scheint zu sein dass sagen
auf organische ebene ja auch eine
empfindsamkeit lücke das ist aber nicht
würde gerne noch da was sagen sie denen
freut mal ganz kurz in schutz nehmen wo
ich ihn sonst immer so schnell wie
möglich abbauen möchte das ist klar dass
frauen das nicht gerne hören dass reif
und unreif die falschen worte sind da
gemeint und auch die fragilität von
freud war nicht ganz so gelungen
aber es gibt da ein sohn was biologisch
praktisches also der mann fängt ja viel
früher an sein
sein penis anzufassen nämlich gleich und
darf es dann zum teil
das kleine mädchen fängt auch vorne an
darf es dann nicht das ist das problem
das zweite ist dass diese anteile über
die wir sprechen die inneren die fängt
sie ja mit mit glück oder irgendwann
erst mit 13 15 also wenn sie ihr innen
entdeckt also ganz vorne weg es gibt
kein häuschen das alles zu macht weil
sie könnte nämlich schon vorher ein
fassen dass aber ein thema für sich
aber diese idee dass sich da rein zu
fassen das hat jetzt mit synapsen und
hirn zu tun wenn das nicht angelegt
verbunden mit lust ist dann
ist es auch noch nicht da und deswegen
leider was freud gesagt hat ich würde
jetzt nicht unreif und reifen nehmen
sondern ich lerne erst etwas später mein
innenleben im hirn mit lust zu
verknüpfen also man könnte behaupten
jahre für frauen aber warum muss das
rein heißt es auch bei verlust fähigkeit
früher gebannt wird als die
geschlechtsreife das also kinder
beispielsweise schon früh erahnen müssen
dort empfindung reicher zu werden das
würde ja auch auf das uni verbot führen
dass man im prinzip lernen muss an sich
selbst lust erfahren zug ich würde gerne
ein lautes schreien des jahr brüllen
weil das ist das wo wir sexuellen immer
da diese diese früh sexualisierung
vorgeworfen bekommen wenn wir über lust
sprechen bei kleinen menschen das ist
weil wir mit unserer erwachsen brille
drauf gerungen aber wenn wir dem
unternehmen würde dann hat jedes kind
jedes kleine kind fast sich genüsslich
und gerne an
es ist kein unterschied für den kleinen
den fingern mund stecken den c oder die
hand an das genital und das gehört schon
zu dem problem erfahren körper
erfahrungsschatz den ein mensch hat wenn
man im handwerk hand weg dann hat man
auch kein gefühl für den körper und ein
gefühl zu haben verbunden im hirn das
spürt man mehr und man passt auch dass
auf die dinge auf die man kennt und
spürt und benennen kann man kommt ja das
führt zu einer einer der thesen dies in
diesem sehr anregenden buch besonders
anregend fand sie sagten nämlich der
orgasmus ist organisch eigentlich so
dass er durch den sexualakt selbst gar
nicht in bester weise stimuliert und
hervorgebracht werden kann das heißt der
akt des kreuzes ist gar nicht der der
menschen in bester weise zum orgasmus
führt nun gut es gibt ein kapitel über
die masturbation und ich habe dann
sorgen die unterscheidung zwischen soul
orgasmus orgasmus oder mit mehreren
entscheidungen ist gar nicht wer auf das
meeres dass eine weitere person anwesens
die mich sozusagen ablenkt wenn ich das
alleine mache ist das eine andere
erfahrung und die ist ihre doppel das
heißt also ich kann nicht sagen das ist
fehlt es manchmal noch heute sagt er ist
nur eine vorübung also oder für für
männer oder frauen die sozusagen keinen
partner bekommen nein das ist eine
besondere form der selbst
und der selbstwahrnehmung und auch der
kreativen selbstentwicklung in dem
augenblick wo da zwei personen dabei
sind ist es ein kommunikatives geschehen
ist ein gemeinsames geschehen
und damit das auch sehr schnell ethisch
also das heißt es ist sehr schön ich
beschreibe das seine erfahrungen die ich
in einer synagoge gemacht hat wo ein
junger mann den rabbiner gefragt hat wie
ist das dürfen wir miteinander schlafen
bevor wir verheiratet sind und seine
antwort ist wer miteinander schläft ist
verheiratet und sagen in dem augenblick
bist du für den anderen oder ihr
einander verantwortlich und dann sind
wir dass das hat vor nachteile
der nachteil ist dass ich dass mich
darum kümmern muss
der vorteil ist aber natürlich dass man
eine gemeinsame erfahrung macht um diese
gemeinsamen erfahrung ist aber nicht
reduzierbaren auf die einsame und
umgekehrt also eine qualitative
unterscheidung zwischen dem mono
orgasmus und im duo orgasmus weil es ein
kommunikatives geschehen ist und sie
sagen auch da entstehen besondere
bindungskräfte das ist ja ein leicht
sagen die konservative denkfigur man
könnte auch sagen da geht einfach ins
bett hat lust miteinander und mit
bindung ist da gar nicht sogar
neurobiologisch ist da bindung was und
christine oxytocin und andere dinge das
ist bindet also man könnte sagen doch
die natur will ja schon wenn man dass
man da auf die idee kommen könnte ein
nachwuchs eventuell entstehende
nachwuchs zu versorgen sind diese
bindungen bei frauen und männern in der
erfahrung gleich also gibt es dann gar
nicht das was man so kalten sex nennt
ohne horn sind sozusagen als person
erkennt oder erkennen will
na klar gibt es das also dass das vögeln
aber immer der körper schüttet trotzdem
diese hormone aus aber der mensch ist ja
immer noch meist ein bestimmer man kann
sich auch heimo hormonen entziehen
es sei denn der große das verliebtsein
dann das ist ja wie eine gehirnkrankheit
da kann man das ist da kann man sich
nicht mehr entscheiden das nicht zu
wollen
aber ein sex angeht schon also auch da
ist sich sozusagen kognitiv noch steuer
ja ja es gibt natürlich von der von dem
reinen trieb ablassen bis hin zu einer
gemeinsamen lebensführung einer
erotischen lebensführung beim
romantischen wochenende oder wie auch
immer gibt es jegliche denkbaren
zwischenstufen und das muss man auch mal
sagen und dann ist die frage wie man
sich dazu verhält
nur zu denken dass liebe dass man sie
vorkommen explodieren kann ist natürlich
ein trugschluss ja filme gibt es
freundschaft mit gewissen mit benefits
wie man heute sagt gericht also
irgendwie zwei blöcken workaholic new
york machen das was passiert eine person
verliebt es ist zwar fast zwangsläufig
irgendwann will jemand irgendwie bea und
dann aber ein problem und die saison
diese liefert die nase ist eine feine
idee wenn sie funktioniert wunderbar
aber es ist dann auch sehr selten zum
glück also die ln fischer unterscheidet
uns im gehirn ja drei verschiedene
zentren verliebtsein bindung und dann
ist ihre begehren und die interagieren
aber können auch sich wechselseitig
stören oder unabhängig agieren und das
hat einen vorteil weil dadurch entstehen
sehr viele kombinationen und das ist
genau das was wir neben denn kultur und
unsere ganzen liebesgeschichten und
roman aber auch unser privatleben läuft
genauso ab jetzt complicated wie man
kann ja ist sein leben sie haben von
einem kontinuum gesprochen sagen wir von
einem von einer sagen rein funktionalen
entlasten masturbation bis zum höchsten
gemeinsamen liebesglück ein gedanke in
ihrem buch besteht darin dass der
orgasmus da wo er sich zweckfrei gibt
also vom gewissen erwartungen und
funktionen insbesondere denen der
fortpflanzung entlastet ist am reinsten
am schönsten am reichsten ist das heißt
ein zweck an sich kein mittel zum zweck
ja das ist ja deswegen auch interessant
und das fand ich ein gedanke die man
dann weiterführen könnte für
homosexuelle paare beispielsweise ist
das ja eigentlich eine fast positive
beschreibung war dort der fortpflanzungs
zweck an sich erstmal beckfeld das heißt
es ist reines lustspiel das gar nicht
unter einem zweck verdacht stehen muss
ist ja interessanter gedanke jetzt komme
ich gerade auf einen anderen das ja zwei
ich nämlich zwei männer können ja dann
sich nicht fortpflanzen
trotzdem gibt es oft also die sind die
generative potenz also die die spermien
und dies ist das leben was da drin es
ist ja trotzdem lag also dieses schießen
des mannes das scheint eine wahnsinnige
biologische psychologische bedeutung zu
haben also was klienten
gleich fragen wenn es um zum beispiel
der realisation geht com kommt dann da
genug raus ja die spermien machen zehn
prozent aus man sieht den unterschied
nicht aber diese idee alleine und das
beschreiben männer das m ich kann zeugen
und das ist da egal mit wem ich jetzt
sechs ab würde ich jetzt behaupten so
von dem was ich höre bei meinauto.de wir
beschreibt das also das was der mensch
ist jetzt noch erstmal nur der mensch
etwas nach außen geht die milliarden und
das ist die akkuleistung bei mann oder
frau schlichten einfach die geburt der
bären als ich entlasse jemanden und auch
die dass die laktation also dass milch
die das stillen ich gebe etwas nach
draußen ja und der mann hat nur diese
eine möglichkeit das ist in der
regulation wäre die frau das kind
sozusagen in die welt in die welt setzt
das wäre das coral korrelat das nach
außen kommen ja aber jetzt noch etwas zu
dieser rheinlust es ist eben ein
völliger denkfehler von schilden
religionen die sagen nun also die
sexualität die wir haben ist nur für die
fortpflanzung
denn wenn das wäre warum pflanzen wir
uns nicht genau eine woche im jahr
die tiere waren selektive ersten akt
jetzt endlich nach gewissens kleid mit
allen möglichkeiten damit sind und
zweitens warum sind wir dauer aktiv also
uns beschäftigt dieses thema eigentlich
permanent wenn das nur der reproduktion
diente dann würde ich auch die evolution
einen fehler machen das ist nämlich eine
energieverschwendung
sondern das wird geht dann in die
partnerschaft in die verantwortung
das kommunikations geschehen um die
kultur mit all dem programm was wir
haben einschließlich dieser sendung
nicht
und deswegen hat dann schon also kalt
terrasse die ja auch mal findet der
pille hatten sich angesagt wir müssen
das komplett trennen also die leute
sollen ihre konten einfrieren lassen und
dann kritisieren und wenn sich ein kind
wollen dann wird das sozusagen künstlich
arrangiert naja es steigert ist ein
klinisch ist eine these also um es ganz
klar zu trennen also wir haben dann
einfach unsere freiheit
eine pille oder sonstige irgendwelche
mechanischen oder sonstige
verhütungsmittel und und wenn wieder ein
kind bekommt nur das ist eine eine
trennung die natürlich die allermeisten
menschen dann noch nicht mitmacht das
nicht mehr wahnsinnig wenn ich das ich
man könnte so viele dieser gedanke ich
vielleicht ist die kinder die
reproduktion ein beiläufiges
nebenprodukt wir brauchen vielleicht nur
ein kind jeder und so und das war die
produkte und das passt auch zum gehirn
dann ist lebens zu leben weil der mensch
ist ein bindungs tier und er soll
einfach ist schön leben während er hier
ist und das passiert meist nicht alleine
mit der mono anfangs also mit sondern
mit dem du also mit den gibt's genug
studien so dass man dann blüht und lebt
länger lebt weniger schmerzen hat und
wenn man berührt wird
und das war doch mal gar keinen
nachwuchs da das richtige einheit mal
ist ja eine frage gab jetzt die haben
sich schon angesprochen ja bisschen
rätselhaft ist ja die mich aus
evolutionärer sicht weshalb ist den
weiblichen orgasmus über hergibt das
klingt wie eine seltsam kritische frage
aber es scheint ein offenes rätsel der
evolutionstheorie zu sein
wie stehen sie zu dieser frage haben sie
überhaupt eine antwort darauf
das ist doch wirklich merkwürdig also
hier ist ja es ist passt nur zu der
these es ist was schönes mann mann mann
lebt man spürt sich der körper dafür die
das blut schießt durch mann ist lebendig
also das ist ein genuss und es macht
lässt ein länger leben als geschenk der
evolution als ausdruck höchster lebendig
jagd also dass man sich mit den media
theorien beschäftigt dann wird lange
diskutiert und dann heißt mehr so genau
wissen wir das nicht und das ist nur ein
teil antwort und ich habe dann ein
philosophisches buch ist ja immer auch
ein bisschen spekulativ ja wir über die
nächsten hinausgehen kann ich sagen ja
gut dann ist das eben nicht funktional
dann ist das die reine lust dann ist das
eben nur zum vergnügen da und damit ist
die frau ein bisschen besser gestellten
hat der nada weil bei einem mann ist das
nicht der fall und in der es darum geht
dass wir kultiviert werden und dass wir
eine natürliche phänomen oder
biologische phänomene sozusagen in die
anthropologie hinein verlängern
dann haben wir hier ein gutes beispiel
hoch es geht auch sprachlich und in der
selbstbeschreibung dieser erfahrung
das sehen wir jetzt in einem kurzen
filmausschnitt aus dem film la petite
mort von anni gisler aus dem jahre 2008
die explosion
[Musik]
nur moment
es ist definitiv schluss
[Musik]
da werden die höchsten register gezogen
es steigert sich als steigert sich mal
mit ausgekoppelt aus raum und zeit ist
das eine art auf die philosophen wenn
eine transzendenz eine quasireligiöse
erfahrung also transzendenz kann man
einerseits religiöses esoterisch
kosmologische betrachten also ich mach
das nicht das kann man und wenn frauen
oder männer beim menschen das so
beschreiben okay aber ich finde das viel
interessanter wenn wir das sozusagen
lebenspraktische lebensphilosophische
betrachten das würde dann bedeuten dass
es etwas im alltag gibt was aussah
alltäglich ist um dieses außer
alltägliches suchen wir dauernd die
leute die extrem sport treiben werden
wir ein in urlaub fahren denn wir ein
fest machen wenn wir uns der erotik in
geben und wenn wir kunst betrachten und
der orgasmus in der zweisamkeit oder in
der einsamkeit ist etwas was nichts
kostet das heißt hier können dass
tatsächlich an uns selber mehr oder
weniger regelmäßig generieren und müssen
jetzt nicht umfänglich eine reise buchen
oder in ein teures restaurant gehen das
finde ich das schon mal sehr interessant
dass die natur uns diese möglichkeiten
hat und wenn das aber stattfindet der
was heißt dann transzendenz und das ist
nicht so ganz einfach das zu beschreiben
und da muss man schauen was sagen ich
geh da raten also die die
romanschriftsteller oder die lyriker
oder was sagen künstler also hier eine
eine film
macherin oder was sagen die normalen
menschen wenn sie darüber sprechen
also ja die sprache hören wie es
beschrieben wird aber was sie gesagt hat
seine form der alltäglichen auskopplung
die sogar so beschrieben insbesondere
von frauen wie ich jetzt in der reha hat
als auskopplung von raum und zeit man ja
eigentlich weder sich selbst noch ist
man in dem was man wirklichkeit so nennt
genau
mir ist ein kleiner gedanke eingefallen
das schöne gefühl warum das frauen dann
so gratis bekommen haben so groß und die
erklärung von vorhin das der frau ist ja
nur zwölf stunden befruchten ich die
natur wäre würde ich das genauso machen
dass ich eigentlich mehr lust hat was
sie hat was wir aber kulturell manchmal
versuchen vielleicht dann doch zu
dämpfen aber wenn sie dürfte hätte eine
frau unter umständen mehr lust als der
mann
und dann ist gesichert dass dies ist
eine idee zwölf stunden da hat sie
wahrscheinlich lust auf sex und wird
auch befruchtet
aber dann wäre es gut wenn sie sich dem
alltag entziehen könnte also vielleicht
ist deswegen die große gitarrist da
damit sie sich in die wonnen stürzt und
nicht nur nüsse sammelt ich muss jetzt
an die jäger und aber da denken aber
heute ist ja noch besseres beispiel also
dass aber die haben die frage ist dass
ich etwas erfahren wir da und da also
ich war ziemlich enttäuscht von der von
den roman schriftstellern habe dann aber
die schulze stelle gefunden in einem
roman der ich ganz in rot ist nämlich
roberto l und de la rosa wo es nur eine
der name der rose rose wo eben ein
bauernmädchen den novizen verführt und
der seinem hohen alter seine einzige
liebes erfahrung in worte fassen muss
aber keine worte hat weil es damals
keine gab
und dann auch hart ist eigentlich sünde
aber das war so unglaublich schön das
kann doch gar nicht als gewollt und dann
am ende zu einer formulierung kommt wo
er sagt wer diese erfahrung macht schaut
auf das normale leben mit einer gewissen
ist nicht sagen der verachtung aber
ernüchterung das normale leben das ist
so
es ist unnormal dass sie so banal das
ist trivial das ist schal und jetzt
haben wir für einen kurzen augenblick
den vorschein
von ja den tor zu einer zu einem
ekstatischen oder zu einem anderen leben
das möglich wäre natürlich immer nur
ganz kurz also die glückseligkeit von
der ich spreche geht ja vielleicht
zurück auf aristoteles auf die steuer
nur was die dort meine ist nicht die
glückseligkeit sondern eigentlich das
glückliche gute leben ja sagen ich soll
eigentlich die glückseligkeit ist das
sind wenige augenblicke wenn wir
permanent glückselig wären das ging gar
nicht
ja das werde auch die glückseligkeit
entwerten sondern ab und zu haben wird
das also sind wir heiraten wenn wir uns
sexuell befriedigen wenn wenn besondere
augenblicke in unserem leben aber sie
sind selten aber ihr braucht ja also es
gibt diese spitze der glückseligkeit
herr sloterdijk hat ja ein buch neulich
darüber geschrieben das hieß dass
schelling projekt da gibt es einen sehr
schönen satz den menschen macht die
natur die augen auf und erkennt sich
selbst das heißt der mensch in dieser
orgasmus erfahrung gewinnt eine neue
perspektive auf das was wir sie sagten
jetzt das sind nur einige sekunden bei
frauen ist das hier anders man ließ
davon dass das mehrere minuten oder
sogar stunden anhalten können aber das
stimmt nicht also das würde ich gerne
wieder am anfang kurz angedeutet habe
also wenn man man muss angucken also so
pragmatisch ist was lebt sich entlädt
sich im orgasmus die erregung die vorher
aufgebaut ist und die tendenz ist eben
dass männer schnelles schreiben nutzen
und den rest des körpers ignorieren und
auch der geschlechtsverkehr selbst
ziemlich schnell stattfindet und dann
ist nicht so viel erregt und ich spreche
mit männern gebe hausaufgaben mit es
gibt eine ganze tantrische sehne die
männer die sich dort aufhalten und ihren
ganzen körper erotisierend anfassen und
auch die langsamkeit entdecken schloss 6
und dann ist ja alles da auch ganz viel
längere orgasmen haben das ist ein
standardspruch bei mir mit einer
hausaufgabe zu hause befasst sich
befassen sich mit dem penis in ruhe
genussvoll alle wenn sie wiederkommen
sagen so orgasmus hatte ich noch nie
also sie können es auch genau also ich
spreche ja auch dann von einer von einem
kreativitäts modell das heißt also die
zeit davor aber auch die zeit danach ist
viel wichtiger als haben diese diese
kurze episode den ich sie auch schnell
vorbei wenn man tatsächlich
genau wie sie das eben beschrieben haben
sich gut vorbereitet und ist und den
ganzen körper einbezieht und die ganze
existenz und mit fantasie und es gibt
einen roman wo das 400 seiten
beschrieben wird dann endlich zu diesem
diesen höhepunkt kommt und man darf
nicht gleich sofort weg gelöst oder dann
die zigarette an macht sondern versucht
das zu verbinden spüren es gibt eben
diese schöne formulierung einem rilke
gedicht du musst dein leben ändern und
der orgasmus sagt dass ab und zu ein
bisschen was natürlich nicht er sagt
nicht wie ich habe das gefühl ich denke
ich denke schon dass eine andere welt
wird möglich ihre erfahrungen da wird
sichtbar was heißen also was was wird
beschrieben es gibt ein wunderbares buch
für frauen 30 frauen ihre orgasmen
beschreiben und das beste was ich
gefunden habe viel besser als die natur
und da geht es nicht nur diese einheits
erfahrungen und das dass man verschmilzt
mit irgendetwas oder dass man wird sich
and zeitlich und räumlich ist sondern
auch so formulieren dass höchste
unheilig das himmlische berührt sich mit
dem fleisch listen festen das
amoralische kommt dann plötzlich ins
spiel und dass das fand ich sehr
interessant und es ist geht dann
wirklich darum daraus eine erfahrung zu
machen
mit der man dann ein bisschen das leben
korrigieren man hat ein frieden
plötzlich man hat ja immer mit einem so
ein bisschen aber da ist ja irgendwie
kann man die ganzen frustrationen die
aggressoren auch gegen bestimmten
menschen etwas mit geld wieder gestern
erlebt hat und diese ganze das vergisst
man für einen augenblick das heißt das
ist nicht nur eine körperliche reinigung
es ist natürlich auch eine seele ist ja
es ist eine entladung von spannung was
würde denn die subkultur zu lebens
ästhetisch oder alltäglichen bedeuten
also was würden sie sagen sind die
stellschrauben oder die erfahrungen des
orgasmus in welche richtung weisen die
für die alltäglichen praktiken er ist
für mich ist das eindeutig sich spüren
also sich spüren und partner spüren wenn
wir schnell sind und laufen spüren wir
wenig und das sind die stellschrauben
dass man vielleicht wenn der orgasmus so
schön ist dass man daran erinnert werden
ach ja ich habe einen körper ich will
ihnen spüren
und auch manchmal mit einem partner
zusammen lernen auch er oder sie auch
den körper spürt also ich nenne es ja
mal spielspaß mal wenn sie nicht das ist
was ist es denn im leben das schöne
leben sich zu spüren und in kontakt mit
anderen zu sein im spüren aber laufen
wir nicht gerade ein bisschen gefahr
nicht denn geht's an ein ehepaar das
vielleicht 42 ist zwei kinder hat marke
von acht jahren sehr getakteten alltag
die haben dann sex und stehen unter
dieser normative extrem hohen erfahrung
erst aufwendig inszenierten zum lernen
sich zeit zu nehmen
daran scheitert ist ja im alltag eher
und die lustlosigkeit mit sex hat auch
mit diesen orgasmus erwartungen spüren
fängt auch viel von weiter vom orgasmus
spüren
also wir haben tatsächlich orgasmus
industries gr ein tag in dem nicht in
den online zeitschriften irgendetwas
dazu kommt und dann frage ich mich muss
das denn nun wirklich sein ja also
einerseits ist ein großes bedürfnis und
die leute wollen also die autoren wollen
aufklären sondern auf der angesagte
regen sie diese leute die ganze zeit ein
permanenter druck auf gm ausgeübt und
aufgebaut und dann ausgeübt und ich
finde das sehr problematisch
also damit wird auch dann verdient also
in der bild zeitung
zum beispiel ist es das jeden tag und
als am besten ignoriert dass er und das
geht eben nicht so gut dass man kann
auch den kind nicht sagen bitte denkt
nicht dran denken sie jetzt nicht an den
eiffelturm das geht eben nicht der druck
ist so subtil und täglich und immer da
haben sie recht es geht immer um das
optimieren dass das sage ich bitte nimm
den orgasmus weg heute gibt es ihnen
vielleicht gar nicht das ist ein schock
für viele also nur spüren sich auf dem
weg dahin bewegen aber nicht kommen
das praktizieren leute und es wird
spannend weil dann ist er wirklich nicht
da der druck kam nicht da sein wenn man
sagt heute gibt es keinen orgasmus
eindruck zum spüren wie es ist wenn man
nicht immer dahin jagt es ist schwer ist
wie gesagt ja es geht an die präsenz des
orgasmus kennen gibt es insbesondere
einem vergleichsweise in dieser
popularität 9 bereich der pornografie
die ja sich um nichts anderes als die
inszenierung eines einer operation als
ziel dieses aktes
wie ist denn das ist das eine
banalisierung die falsche erwartungen
weckt oder eine befreiung die horizonte
freilegen
das ist die dialektik der aufklärung
sie haben es sie haben einerseits dass
das kann auch gegen alice schwarzer
sagen gesagt nein das muss man komplett
verbieten weil es ein ja aber seien teil
einer emanzipation dh also früher
durften nur ganz wenige sich diese
bilder anschauen oder die filmchen die
gedreht wurde und heute ist das ein
massen film mit weltweit
das ist unglaublich und das können sie
auch nicht abstellen also offensichtlich
gibt es ja auch das bedürfnissen auf der
anderen seite ist wie geht man damit um
vor allen dingen jugendlichen
wir wissen nicht wie diejenigen die
damit von vornherein aufgewachsen sind
und 30 jahren leben damit umgehen das
wissen wir nicht wir alle sind damit
noch nicht aufgewachsen und können damit
er vielleicht auch ihr mann liebt ihn er
umgeht
das heißt da ändert sich glaube ich
wirklich etwas diese bilder welt die
sich jetzt in diesem ganzen gehirn und
fest dass gerade eine sendung darüber
ddr oder eine große untersuchung ist
wurde schon mit neunjährige zehnjährige
elfjährige das alles sehen und ein ganz
anderes vokabular benutzen als wir das
vielleicht noch aber sie beschreiben in
diesem buch eine schöne szene wie sie
als schülerin in dänemark an einem zahl
der laden am kiosk sind und da gibt es
diese trommel heftigen und sie sagen das
war für sie befreiend und schön gegners
diese einblicke in diese welt kann ja
gegenüber von der schule das hat keinen
gestört und ich habe auch gar nicht auf
da reingeguckt das ist ja jetzt also
wenn man etwas nicht verboten man sah da
diese gerollten zeitungen in dem langen
automaten und mich hat es nicht
geschadet zu mögen ja leute jetzt
schauen sie haben doch das wäre das
verbot macht ja
reizvoll also ich finde aber auch heute
ist ja auch nicht verboten und das ist
zu viel
jetzt ist es auf jedem kanal selbst der
der es nicht sehen will oder die die es
nicht sehen will muss ich sehen und das
ist ein großes problem bei porno weil
ist was ich mir vor gewählt haben wir
den skripten in hirn mit den synapsen
was wird mit lust verbunden
wie macht man was da haben da gibt es
untersuchungen so jugendliche anderes
gibt also leute die sehr spiel wir
hatten sie das auch in der partie das
safari unter diesen skripten leiden
jetzt haben wir in den praxen nicht so
viele sehr junge leute weil es teuer ist
es nicht von der kasse in deutschland
nicht wirklich getragen und es gibt aber
wenn man in dem business also merkt man
dass die viele junge männer investoren
und das problem haben gleich zu kommen
also die trainieren sie vier bis sechs
jahre an die zahlen sind 13 12 13 jahre
alt mit pommes ist pornografie bis bis
dem ersten richtigen partner sechs live
sex sex sex mit 17
so ist digital 17,3 da hat man schon
viel zu viele jahre die scripts
verinnerlicht und das bedeutet für viele
junge männer wenn der echte 6 kommt
kommen sie schnell weil das wieder was
schnelle reiben das spannen das drehen
und auch jugendliche also ich spreche
mit jugendlichen ist es keine
untersuchung aber ich spreche mit
jugendlichen machen dinge mit musik
sogar selbst sagen finde ich eigentlich
bescheuert aber ich mache es also männer
und frauen weiß ich es gesehen haben es
ist also wird auch immer normativität
erzeugt ja die die aus dem ruder
gelaufen also er ja es ist jetzt
konservativ was ich sage aber ich
vermute dass ich kann es ja bestätigt
wenn wir von den künsten sprechen auch
dass es in ihrem buch kerngedanke es
gibt eine vergleichsweise darstellungs
armut im orchester sie sagen es gibt
eine kunstform die für den orgasmus
besonders geeignet auf seiner und ihrer
rhythmik und zeitlichkeit
das ist die musik und sie sind ja selber
auch komponist und wir wollen uns mal
ein beispiel einer komposition von ihnen
anhören die solitude noch türen für
piccolo oboe wo sie diese erfahrung
musikalisch zur darstellung bringen
[Musik]
soweit dieser kurzer ausschnitt frau
henning bin ich mir vorstelle würden sie
das einspielen können und sagen denk mal
so darüber ja ganz interessante
erfahrung
und wenn man hört piccolo erwartet und
jetzt ganz beeindruckt der lange erste
es ist wie ein land ohne das ganze ding
aber diese länger was für eine ruhe und
was für eine empfinden und schon
ermöglicht ist und dann nur so kleine
das führte wohin
und ich sage jetzt nichts gespürt habe
ich muss jetzt mal klarstellen naja also
zunächst einmal in die darstelle des
orgasmus inter in der musik ist sehr
sehr selten frauen dafür zeit das waren
20 sekunden ja bei uns gibt eine
berühmte stelle bei wagner im kontext
von tristan sollte aber um das allein
anzuhören bräuchten wir mindestens zehn
minuten weil man da gehört alles dazu
dass die forschung danach spielen und so
und das hier ist ein stück wo es um mal
etwas ähnliches geht eigentlich nicht um
sexualität sondern es vertont einer idee
von adorno über die wahrheit mann ist in
der wahrheit oder ist so mehr zu wissen
und um das zu wissen müsste ich
heraustreten und das ist ganz analog
auch zum orgasmus nicht vergessen
ich weiß das nicht also wenn ich anfange
währenddessen nachzudenken da habe ich
schon irgendwas versäumt und erst danach
kann ich mich erinnern und diese
erfahrung habe ich dann aus komponiert
für eine piccolo brauche dafür 15 15
minuten es gibt in der mitte dass ich
einen dreiminütigen teil der wenn diese
diesen ausgedehnten wirklich ganz lang
ausgedehnten augenblick fast der
glückseligkeit so und das aber und
natürlich ist das ganze stück in diesem
moment ist in diesem gefühl komponiert
und das ist der anfang und das siegel
atmung kann ein opfer ist tatsächlich
eine phrase über 20 sekunden denen das
ist dass ich wie sehr ein ton der ein
bisschen
mariniert und dann wieder abgeben da
kommt die nächste phase und wird es ein
bisschen kürzer und schneller
aber das geht so etwa neun minuten und
dann kommt man in diesen in diesen
ekstatischen schönen augenblick und dann
geht man wieder heraus wenn ich jetzt 1
1 den orgasmus selber darstellen wollte
das schon ein großes orchester ein tun
aber eigentlich natürlich das ist
entsetzlich reiterinnen waren das war
doch das spannende in dem ton die
möglichkeit man spürte diesen raum die
freiheit wo geht das händen wo kann es
ihnen gehen mit kleinen u
wie schön dass wir so darüber sprechen
können wenn wir von den möglichkeiten
sprechen und das ist vielleicht auch ein
letztes großes thema sie sprechen in
diesem buch und das ist ja auch eine
zentrale institution der 68er bewegung
beispielsweise von den politischen hut
tropischen potenzialen des orgasmus wo
würden sie die insbesondere sehen also
zunächst mal könnte man sagen
spinnst du tanja ist so kurz und das ist
so privat was hat denn das mit der
großen menschheitsfragen zu tun könnte
man sagen aber man kann sich ja mal
folgendes überlegen wie wäre die
menschheit und ich meine wirklich alle
länder alle menschen und alle frauen auf
der welt wir müssten die leben das sie
in schöner regelmäßigkeit diesen
schönsten der schönen augenblicke
genießen können was würde das bedeuten
wir müssen alle religionen umbauen wir
müssen die rechtssysteme umbauen wir
müssen die moralvorstellungen umbauen
wir müssten ökologische gleichheit
herstellen wir müssten das verhält sich
ein mann und frau endlich mal richtig
die die balance zu bringen
und und und und wir wissen sofort das
ist eine riesige aufgabe aber ich denke
man sollte und könnte und ich tue das
dann auch wirklich in dieser dimension
so weit zu ende denken das ist das was
ich mit dem mit mechanischen verbinde
das heißt also wenn meine politischen
philosophie zb bei adorno oder arbeit
der ideale mann zu einer puk befreiten
gesellschaft oder von einer kommenden
demokratie die wirklich sozusagen welt
bürgerliche absicht für alle gilt und
nicht nur für einige reiche länder wenn
das hoch spielt dann sollen die ja auch
allen schönes leben führen und innerhalb
dieses schönes leben höhen schönen
lebens hat man dann durch
die schöne erotik und dann hat man dann
irgendwann auch dann diesen zentralen
moment dieser aerotec von daher kann man
tatsächlich aus einem orgasmus ein
ganzes philosophisches programm ableiten
und warum jetzt kann man umgekehrt
fragen warum so vor allen religionen
aber durchaus auch moralwächter und da
es ihr aber teilweise genauso schlimm
die amerika warum sie dann hier
eingreifen in diese lust erfahrung weil
da ist man frei das potenzial ist das
dann aber so wir sprechen ja jetzt erst
mal sein heterosexuellen beziehung
unseren fokus auf die frau würde nicht
sagen dass das immer noch unsere haupt
thematischen bezug auf den orgasmus ist
die befreiung der lust der frau als
emanzipatorisch bestrebung für die
gesamte gesellschaft für die sexualität
ich würde es nicht auf dem orgasmus
beschränken für die sexualität ist dass
ein essenzielles thema also das ist wie
sie heutzutage ist der unterschied
zwischen mann und frau wie das alles ist
ja strukturelle strukturell also dass da
gibt es viel zu tun weil es hat mit man
kann nicht frei sein wenn man daran zu
wissen bekommt dass man dinge nicht soll
und weniger wert ist und das ist nicht
nur für die frau schlecht sondern auch
für den eventuell in männlichen partner
dann ist es für alle besser wenn die
geschlechter von denen es ja dann auch
sogar mehr gibt als 2 alle da sein
dürften so wie sie sind in ihrer werte
gleich wird auch für den mann bedeuten
dass er sich gleichsam lebens rhythmisch
ein beispiel einen möglichkeiten des
weiblichen orgasmus nimmt aha also immer
super tor ich muss jetzt erstmal die
frau nicht liegen aber ja aber es ist
dann letztendlich relativ bald eine cola
situation weil auch der mann aus seiner
angestammten rolle als erhellten und als
superman und so weiter oder vielleicht
auch als kriegs führer sein muss
natürlich daraus auch befreit werden und
der ist schlecht der fast genital der
frau ist diskriminiert und die gefühle
des mannes konnte mich von wegen männer
können das nicht sie können den anderen
nicht lesen sie können haben weniger
gefühle nein die haben gelernt dass sie
so tun müssen also wieso ist bis sie
selbst an glauben dass sie weniger haben
eine frechheit
wir sehen die dialogischen unwuchten und
wiesen miteinander zusammenhängt letzte
frage an sie
mit der bitte um eine kurze antwort wenn
sie jetzt heranwachsende töchter hätten
im alter von 15 jahren
welchen zentralen einrad würden sie ihn
in bezug auf den orgasmus geben
naja ich fange ganz früh an wenn ich
eine hätte hätte sie schon einen namen
für genital ein wohlwollendes und nicht
am popo vorne
das wirkt sich auf den ganzen rest eine
ganz schwierige frage weil ich keine
kinder habe und auch keine töchter
vielleicht würde ich es mit guter musik
versuchen super gehalten
wir nennen die dinge beim namen wie
ordnen sie rhythmisch gut ein und dann
seid ihr als leiter und als gesellschaft
vielleicht auf einem besseren weg vielen
vielen dank für diese stunde von der
gedanke höhe frau henning hermann kopf
danke dass sie daran
[Musik]